Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an episode called “Mother's Remote”
from a Sci-fi drama anthology “On Children.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
Chen Shu-Li is a middle-aged woman who has
recently been divorced from her husband.
They have a teenage son together named Pei-Wei.
Shu-Li is overly obsessed with her kid and wants
him all to herself. She has even managed to get
the sole custody of Pei-Wei. The mother and son
have recently moved into their new home. A worker
helps Shu-Li carry all the boxes. His footsteps
seem to disgust her, so as soon as the guy leaves,
she starts to mop the floor. Shu-Li is an extreme
germaphobe who is obsessed with sanitation and
feels compelled to clean excessively. While
dusting Pei-Wei’s room, she finds several boxes
under his bed. She brings a suspicious one out
and finds the school’s stamp on it.
She realizes that her son has been using
them to create fake test results to
hide his grades from her. In school,
Pei-Wei is with his friends talking about the
upcoming graduation trip. They have planned to
sneak out of the hotel room to go for a bike
ride. As they excitedly discuss the plan,
a female classmate approaches them and asks for a
Pei-Wei’s friend’s jacket. They laugh and hand it
to her, sensing a romantic relationship forming
between them. She gives him a note asking him out
on a date, making the guys playfully tease him.
Before returning home, Pei-Wei prints out a copy
of his fake report card. He plans to use the
stamps at home to make the card look authentic.
Pei-Wei knows that if his mother finds out
about his shenanigan, she will never allow
him to go on the graduation trip, still, he
takes the chance. When he reaches home, he
looks for the box but cannot find it. He pretends
to be studying when his mother enters the room.
He sees that she has the box with her.
A nervous Pei-Wei doesn’t say a word,
knowing that his secret is out. She starts to
scold him but he ignores her entirely. Shu-Li is
enraged at his behavior and gets ever more furious
when he says he lost his actual report card.
Pei-Wei is interested in painting and doodling
but she doesn’t support his hobbies. In contrast,
she blames his doodles for his low grades and
refuses to let him go on the graduation trip.
In a fit of rage, Pei-Wei says that his
father would have let him go. Following that,
Shu-Li quietly leaves him alone. She works till
midnight to calm her anger, then knocks on his
door again. When he doesn’t answer she goes
to a convenience store to get a cigarette.
While smoking at the bus stop, Shu-Li notices
an advertisement playing on a screen nearby.
The actor questions the viewers if their children
are disobedient. This catches Shu-Li’s attention,
making her listen carefully.
Using the latest technology,
scientists have created a remote that
will help parents make their children
do anything they want. They can basically make all
the decisions for the kids without them rebelling.
The advertisement, however, doesn’t explain
what exactly the product is. Moments later,
a man approaches Shu-Li who she recognizes as the
person from the advertisement she just watched. He
asks her if she is interested in the device. The
following morning, Pei-Wei wakes up late and runs
to the door after getting ready. On his way to the
bus stop, he bumps into a man and apologizes.
Because of this, he misses the bus and has to take
a taxi. When the taxi driver states his son also
reads in the same school, he realizes something is
odd. Pei-Wei is experiencing some kind of Deja Vu
because he went through the same experience
the previous morning. When he reaches school,
everyone is already in the class. He joins his
group of friends and asks them what day it is.
They reply that it is June, 7th, Wednesday.
Pei-Wei clearly remembers that it was yesterday
which freaks him out even more.
During break time, they yet again plan
to sneak out of their hotel room on the graduation
trip. Similarly, a girl approaches them asking for
Pei-Wei’s friend’s jacket. Not understanding what
is going on, Pei-Wei chooses to stay quiet. After
a long confusing day when he returns home, he sees
that his box of stamps is still under his bed.
Pei-Wei is confused but he doesn’t want
to risk his mother getting mad again.
He stamps the fake report card and shows
it to his mother who appears disappointed.
She doesn’t call him out for lying and simply asks
him to have his dinner. The following day, Pei-Wei
is again late for school. He gets ready and runs
to the bus stop only to bump into the same guy
for the third time. When he misses his bus and
gets into the exact taxi as the previous day,
he registers he might be stuck in a loop.
He runs to the school and looks at the date which
still happens to be the seventh of June. After
school, he shows his mother the fake card yet
again. However, this time, she doesn't accept it.
She claims that she had given him three chances to
redeem himself but he hasn’t learned a lesson.
A shocked Pei-Wei looks at her in disbelief as
Shu-Li declares if he doesn’t fix his mistake, he
will be stuck in the loop forever. Following that,
she brings out a strange remote and presses the
reset button. This turns back time for Pei-Wei,
making him wake up on the 7th of June for
the fourth time. The remote is a controlling
device she bought from the stranger at
the bus stop. It is used as a torturing
technique to make one’s child obedient.
Pei-Wei wakes up and confronts his mother
but gets no reply. She asks him to make the right
decision and not disappoint her this time. Still,
Pei-Wei does the same. For the next few days, the
loop keeps on repeating. When Pei-Wei finally gets
tired of it, he hands her his real report card to
his mother. Delighted at her first success, she
instantly puts forward another obstacle for him.
Shu-Li knows he hates bitter gourd, so to test
his obedience, she makes him eat it for dinner.
Fearing the remote, he does as told. Furthermore,
she demands he go to cram school starting the next
day. This means that Pei-Wei won’t get to meet his
friends anymore, still, he cannot refuse. To make
him the best in his class, she plans to repeat a
day fifteen times. That way, he can learn the same
chapter fifteen times while his friends only do it
once. On his first day of Cram school, she makes
him wear the clothes of her choice. For the next
fifteen days, he continues going to the “first”
day of class. Pei-Wei hardly has any control
in his life, his only way to survive is to do as
told. The loops make him suffocate but his mother
is too obsessive to understand his sufferings.
One day after class, he goes to the school
and meets his homeroom teacher. When Pei-Wei
insists, the teacher agrees to try to persuade
his mother to let him go on the graduation trip.
He arranges a meeting with her and puts forward
his concerns about Pei-Wei’s mental health
but Shu-Li is adamant about her decision.
She thinks she knows the best for her kid
and completely ignores the teacher’s pleas.
One day, Pei-Wei is in the library when he meets
a girl named Cheng Fang-Lan. She also likes to
doodle, so the two instantly get along. They
talk about several doodle artists and promise
to meet again the next day before separating.
After some days of talking, Pei-Wei skips his cram
class and goes to Fang-Lan’s home for a date. He
is welcomed by her painter mother and musician
father. They are the exact opposite of Shu-Li
which is refreshing for Pei-Wei. The kids go
to the terrace and paint using water guns.
This is the most fun Pei-Wei has ever had.
As they talk about their dreams and aspirations,
Fang-Lan says that she wants to go to New York to
study arts. The next day, Shu-Li gets a call from
Pei-Wei’s teacher who informs her of his absence.
Somewhere else, he and Fang-Lan are enjoying
their date. They go to a photo booth and kiss.
But their date is interrupted by Shu-Li who has
found them after tracking Pei-Wei’s phone.
She takes them out for lunch and asks
Fang-Lan several questions about herself.
When they return home in the evening, she
demands Pei-Wei to stop going to the library
and stop seeing Fang-Lan immediately. Pei-Wei
begs her to let him have this one thing but she
stays put in her decision. Seeing him desperate
for something that she doesn’t like, she uses a
special feature in the remote and resets the
loop. Pei-Wei wakes up in his bed and runs to
meet Fang-Lan but she doesn’t recognize him. He
is devastated to find that because of the remote,
no one except for his mother recognizes him.
Following that day, Pei-Wei gets extremely
sick and can hardly get up. Shu-Li takes care
of him to her best but he only gets weaker.
He often dreams of playing with her
friends and Fang-Lan on a beach but
knows his dream will never come true.
The scene shifts to several years later.
Pei-Wei has grown into a man with a stable job
and high income. He is dating a girl named Zhi-Zhi
and has moved from his mother’s house. Shu-Li,
however, is still very involved in his life and
controls him to some point. Her obsession
with cleanliness has passed onto Pei-Wei.
Shu-Li doesn’t approve of Zhi-Zhi so she is
constantly looking for girls to set him up.
One evening, they meet for dinner where she
has invited one of such girls named Riley.
According to Shu-Li, Riley has recently returned
from America and is looking for a partner.
She tries to engage Pei-Wei in a conversation
with Riley but he clearly isn’t interested. After
dinner, the two are left alone. Riley tells
him that she is actually engaged to a girl.
Her parents do not support her decision and
trick her into joining people for dinner
like she did today. Pei-Wei laughs and reveals
that he also has a girlfriend and didn’t know
she would be here tonight. They talk about her
life in America. When Riley mentions New York,
Pei-Wei reminisces about his first love; Fang-Lan.
He remembers all the time he spent with her like
it was yesterday and still despises his
mother for doing what she did to him.
After returning home that day, he looks for
Fang-Lan’s name on the internet and finds out
she is an artist in New York. Seeing her face
makes him tear up thinking about all the things
he missed in his childhood. The very next
day, he books his mother a flight to Europe
for a vacation. Zhi-Zhi also leaves for
a trip to Australia. When he is alone,
he goes to Shu-Li’s house to look for the
remote. However, he doesn’t know the safe’s
passcode. On her way to the airport, Shu-Li
realizes she has left her passport at home.
When she returns, she finds her son outside her
house with the remote that she used to control
him. She furiously asks him what he plans
to do with it. Pei-Wei approaches her with
the remote but is hit by a vehicle mid-way. The
scene abruptly cuts to the day he met Fang-Lan
for the first time. She looks at him and smiles
while Pei-Wei cries, overwhelmed to see her after
so long. We can assume that after Pei-Wei was
hit by the vehicle, Shu-Li revived him using
the remote. Many fans believe since the remote
hadn’t been used for a long time, it was still
set on the date when Pei-Wei met Fang-Lan. Hence,
when Shu-Li hurriedly pressed it to save her son,
she accidentally sent him to the past.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.